moi je m'appelle Sophie persona ma
petite entreprise mon nom de marque
c'est Sophie de soi donc je suis dans la
couture depuis une dizaine d'années et
j'ai monté ma petite entreprise il y a à
peu près un an alors en fait j'ai
commencé à coudre quand j'ai eu mon
premier enfant puis j'ai eu envie de
réaliser quelque chose pour lui donc
c'est comme ça que je suis venue à la
couture j'ai vraiment pris goût donc
j'ai appris sur le teint la majeure
partie des vêtements et des accessoires
que je crée je crée mes propres patrons
on trace le patron sur un sur un papier
on découpe et à partir du patron on
commence à tailler le à tailler le tissu
donc une fois qu'on a taillé le tissu on
commence par surjeter l'ensemble des
bords du tissu afin que déjà la couture
soit propre et que le tissu ne
s’effiloche pas après il y a la partie
assemblage qu'on va assembler le devant
et le dos pour faire les coutures de
côté et puis après il y a la partie à
l'intérieur ce qu'on appelle la
parmenture qui va être assemblé le
devant et le dos après il y a la
réalisation des petites boutonnières
après il y a l'ourlet du bas donc sur
une robe comme ça on est à peu près sur
une heure et demie de travail moi c'est
vrai que je prends beaucoup de temps
pour choisir un tissu j'adore les
matières j'adore j'adore toucher le
tissu j'adore le travail principalement
avec le coton j'essaie vraiment de mixer
les différents types de tissus de faire
des associations c'est rare que je fasse
une pièce avec un seul tissu c'est vrai
que les gens apprécient je crois un
retour au travail fait main et j'accorde
vraiment une une grande attention aux
finitions donc l'accueil est en général
très bon et je me rends compte que les
personnes apprécient justement
l'originalité des tissus avec lesquels
j'essaie de travailler par rapport à la
grande distribution c'est vrai que
c'est la concurrence est parfois et
parfois difficile mais je crois que les
gens qui connaissent la véritable
qualité du travail à la main revienne
finalement vers ces vers ce genre de
produits au moins pour se faire plaisir
pas dans la vie de tous les jours mais
au moins pour se faire plaisir
la Réunion en voyant toutes les feuilles
de coco qui gaspillent à droite il me
dit il faut valoriser ça en fait tu vois
depuis ton petit
par rapport à ce que comme il regarde
n'était ça va faire comment on
disparaître
la Réunion est très beau pays on a
beaucoup de matières premières locales
sous la main de gosses à droite partout
les objets pour les touristes en général
c'est un panier multifonction
on peut mettre les fruits dedans
ça les gens ils connaissaient
dans les salles de bain
un vide pas
le bloc l'autre qui travaille comme ça
de la vente des communications et c'est
pas moi de commercial aussi
il faut aller voir d'autres choses à
côté aussi j'ai quelqu'un qui est
capable faire de créer son métier en
fait
valoriser ça premièrement à travers les
espos etc les écoles et fleurissent les
hôtels tout ça et puis
à mon téléphone